Is Morbius a hero or a villain?
Is the movie a vampire horror film, or a superhero
movie with fangs?
And most importantly, is it any good?
These are the 6 best and 6 worst things about
"Morbius."
On paper, Jared Leto's Michael Morbius is
a pretty compelling character.
Suffering from a rare and usually fatal blood
disease since birth, he becomes one of the
world's leading experts on artificial blood
and is even awarded a Nobel prize for his
efforts.
"You need a doctor?"
"I am a doctor."
Morbius eventually attempts to cure his condition
by splicing his own DNA with that of vampire
bats, causing him to develop a number of supernatural
abilities and a deep craving for human blood.
Most of the film deals with Morbius' internal
struggle as he tries to balance his new violent
urges with the humanitarian ideals that he's
always tried to live by.
That should be the formula for an emotionally
intense and nuanced antihero story, and at
times, "Morbius" shows glimpses of just that.
Michael has contributed a lot of good to the
world, and as the viewer, you truly believe
that his experiments are largely motivated
by a desire to help others.
At the same time, Morbius can be a pretty
selfish man.
Though his desire to help the world at large
is genuine, his number one motivation seems
to be his own quest for survival.
There's a lot of rich potential in this tension
between selflessness and self-preservation,
and Morbius' vampire transformation could
have been used to explore the character's
inherent duality.
Michael Morbius starts out with a lot of potential
for a nuanced, complex character arc.
Unfortunately, the film wastes no time in
squandering that potential.
Unnecessary time jumps and a poorly written
childhood backstory sequence establish the
character's tragic past in about as clinical
a way as possible.
As a result, the audience has no real emotional
connection to Morbius by the time he undergoes
his transformation.
There's a face-value sympathy in a man who
has spent his whole life on the brink of death,
but the script seems to expect that premise
to be enough, and very little time is spent
developing Michael as an actual character.
Is he actually scared to die?
What is he living for?
What does he want to leave behind?
These are the kinds of questions that, if
they'd been addressed on screen, could have
made for a deeply textured character — perhaps
one more deserving of Jared Leto's bizarre
method acting techniques.
Instead, viewers are graced with a stoic protagonist
with excruciatingly little substance.
One of the best things "Morbius" has going
for it is that the whole aesthetic surrounding
the central character looks pretty cool.
He has long vampire hair.
He wears a black vampire trench coat.
And when he fights, he flies around with a
lightning-quick fighting style that's accentuated
by some very stylish smoky swirly effects.
Some might argue that Morbius' powers rely
too heavily on CGI, but for the most part,
that CGI does its job well.
"Morbius" is never better than when the Living
Vampire is in action.
The film's first major action sequence, which
sees him take down a group of mercenaries
on the ship where he mutates himself, is a
definite highlight, blending the from-the-shadows
tension of the "Batman" movies with the hard-hitting
speed of Zack Snyder's Superman.
The film never explains whether the smoke
trails that accentuate Morbius' movements
are a side-effect of his transformation, a
result of his incredible speed, or what, but
whatever it is, it looks pretty cool.
The special effects culminate in a genuinely
striking scene where Morbius uses his echolocation
to find a single heartbeat in New York City,
then flies to it in a whirlwind of purple
and black.
It's honestly shocking that Leto looks so
convincing as Morbius, considering that he's
nearly twice the character's age.
While the stylish aesthetic created around
the Morbius character is quite effective,
the rest of the movie suffers from a myriad
of visual problems.
Cinematographer Oliver Wood is a seasoned
veteran of his craft, and it would be irresponsible
to hold him solely responsible for the camera
work in "Morbius," but a certain amount of
blame does inevitably fall at his feet.
Wood is perhaps most famous for his work on
contemporary action movies like "Die Hard
2," "Face/Off," and the original "Bourne"
trilogy.
Though the "Bourne" films received critical
acclaim, they've also become notorious in
the years since for popularizing the use of
shaky cam.
Not every issue with the cinematography in
"Morbius" is due to shaky cam, but the technique
is indicative of the larger problems plaguing
the film's cinematic style.
Nearly every scene is shot with the same level
of intensity.
At best, it's mildly nauseating.
At worst, it's practically unwatchable.
Modern superhero movies seem obsessed with
competing for the longest runtime.
Films like "Avengers: Endgame," "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," and "The Batman" all clock in
around the two-and-a-half to three hour range,
which can be a big ask for moviegoers.
Of course, all those films were also very
well received upon release, so it could be
argued that they needed their extra length
to pull everything together.
Still, it's refreshing to see a superhero
movie that keeps things short and sweet.
"Morbius" is listed at an hour and 44 minutes,
and it definitely never dwells too long on
any one scene.
It's a fast and furious movie, and not just
because of the inclusion of Tyrese Gibson.
"Mmm hmm, this is crazy man."
"What're you talking about now?"
"I'm sitting there looking at these images."
In fact, if you compare the final film to
the trailers, you'll see that lots of scenes
and lines were removed for the final cut.
If sitting through the three hours that a
lot of other movies demand these days is a
dealbreaker for you, then you may be glad
to see how brief "Morbius" truly is.
Despite its relatively short runtime, "Morbius"
still has major pacing problems.
It somehow manages to feel both sluggish and
rushed at the same time.
The film opens with a beautiful vista shot
of Costa Rica, where Michael Morbius has traveled
to capture vampire bats.
After a brief shot of him using his own blood
as bait, the film jumps back in time 25 years
for a stilted backstory sequence explaining
his difficult childhood.
After that, it's another abrupt cut to present-day
New York, where Morbius is revealed to have
successfully captured a whole swarm of bats
off screen.
This sort of rapid-fire pacing continues throughout
the film, but it gets even more distracting
once the vampire transformation takes place.
Morbius shows very little emotion in response
to his monstrous state, with only a handful
of loud outbursts to augment his otherwise
stoic demeanor.
If the movie ever slowed down for a second,
it might be able to humanize Morbius and his
struggle a bit more, but instead, the script
keeps jumping between underdeveloped side
characters and overwritten exposition.
There's no time for viewers to catch their
breath, much less develop any tangible emotional
attachments.
Perhaps worst of all, this breakneck pace
makes every section of the movie feel the
same.
The frantic camera work and abrupt scene transitions
make it impossible to determine which moments
are pivotal and which are supplemental, turning
the entirety of "Morbius" into one long, repetitive act.
Like the vampire for which it's named, "Morbius"
is not entirely devoid of life.
Most of the humor and humanity that can be
found in the film comes from Tyrese Gibson
and Al Madrigal, who play a pair of FBI agents
investigating Morbius' activities.
The interplay between Gibson's stone-cold
persona and Madrigal's deadpan comedy is genuinely
funny, with great moments like the latter
bringing a "triple-blessed" vial of holy water
to their interview with the vampire.
Madrigal and Gibson are so entertaining, in
fact, that it's easy to envision a better
version of "Morbius" where they play a larger
role.
Instead, the feds get relegated to a C-tier
supporting cast position, and their occasional
jokes are ultimately drowned out by the film's
cacophonous self-seriousness.
For as good as the FBI agents are in "Morbius,"
the other supporting characters are deeply
lacking.
First and foremost, Matt Smith's Milo, based
loosely on the character Hunger from the Marvel
comics, is a terrible villain.
From the moment he's introduced, it's painfully
obvious that he'll eventually turn evil.
When Michael tells his friend "this isn't
you," it's almost laughable; this is clearly
the only thing Milo was ever written to be.
Equally disappointing is Michael's romantic
subplot with Doctor Martine Bancroft, played
by Adria Arjona.
The actress does her best with a script that
is constantly working against her, but her
efforts just aren't enough.
The greatest trick that "Morbius" pulls is
showing you glimpses of a better movie that
could have been.
The opening title card fades in over a cool
synthwave graphic of hard lines and bright
pinks, teasing a retro aesthetic that never
comes to fruition.
The hard-boiled humor of the FBI agents hints
at pulpy noir, but that tone never gets enough
of a foothold to influence the rest of the
film.
And of course, there are plenty of dark corridors
to evoke the horror genre, which "Morbius"
pulls from heavily.
In the moments where these stylistic touches
are strongest, "Morbius" can be a pretty fun movie.
Unfortunately, the movie refuses to fully
commit to any of its more interesting aesthetics,
languishing mostly in dreary exposition and
ripping off scenes from better movies.
The shot of Michael being swarmed by vampire
bats in his lab is a particularly egregious
instance of this, with a backing score that
elicits memories of Hans Zimmer's "Batman
Begins" score.
Unfortunately, that's a comparison "Morbius"
would probably be better off not even attempting
to make.
"It's not who i am underneath, but what I
do that defines me."
Though it occasionally evokes other genres,
"Morbius" is a superhero movie through and through.
But even in that space, the film feels about
two decades too late.
Rather than those more recent entries in the
genre, "Morbius" is easier to compare to early-2000s
movies like Ben Affleck's "Daredevil."
From the clunky dialogue and overall angsty
tone to the flat side characters, "Morbius"
is a movie that feels stuck in the past — swooping
in from an era when superhero films were bad
more often than they were good, and before
stars like Robert Downey Jr. proved that comic
book exposition didn't have to sound dorky
on camera.
If "Morbius" leaned more into its retro vibe,
if it allowed more of "The Crow" in and less
of "Ghost Rider," perhaps Sony would have
had something.
Instead, we're left with a series of questions
about how a movie like "Morbius" got made
in 2022.
Like most superhero movies of the modern era,
"Morbius" peppers some teases for the future
with its end credits.
There are two post-credits scenes in the film,
both of which focus on the return of Michael
Keaton's Adrian Toomes character from "Spider-Man:
Homecoming."
Because Keaton is a fantastic actor, and because
"Homecoming" is so beloved, it's undeniably
fun to see Toomes brought back into the fold.
"At what cost?"
Great question!
While the cameo is fun at first, it also comes
with its share of problems.
For starters, seeing him at the end of "Morbius"
mostly reminds viewers of a much better movie.
Then there's the matter of how he actually
appears in the "Morbius" universe, which is
confusing to say the least.
The first credits scene shows the sky over
New York being fractured, clearly referencing
the multiverse spell from "Spider-Man: No
Way Home."
However, that spell previously only brought
characters from other realities into the MCU,
not the other way around.
So why does Toomes teleport to Michael Morbius'
world?
How does he get a new Vulture suit without
Chitauri technology?
Is there even a Spider-Man in Sony's Spider-Man
Universe?
These are confusing questions to leave audiences
with at the end of a movie, but given that
the movie is "Morbius," they're a welcome
distraction.
From top to bottom, "Morbius" is a failure.
It ruins all efforts at horror and tension
by rushing through every scene.
It kneecaps a potentially interesting protagonist
by leaving him cold and underdeveloped.
It is an hour and 44 minutes of messy plotting,
clumsy dialogue, and nauseating cinematography,
and it ends with one of the most egregious
CGI slugfests in the history of superhero cinema.
The "Venom" movies might not be masterpieces,
but they embrace their campy tone in a way
that at least makes them entertaining to watch.
"Morbius," on the other hand, is the worst
kind of bad movie — the kind that's so messy
and poorly constructed that it feels like
a chore just to keep watching it.
Sony clearly has high hopes for their interconnected
"Spider-Man" universe, but as the first proper
expansion into that shared continuity, "Morbius"
is a colossal disappointment.
"This movie was a total disappointment.
No thought went into it.
No effort went into it."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.